avec nous ce soir yvan choteau orient
professeur co directeur du centre
d'études en droit économique à
l'université laval bonsoir
bonsoir comment expliquer monsieur chat
orient commun comment une entreprise qui
est soumise pourtant la loi sur les
langues officielles peu comme ça
proposer aux candidats administrateurs
sur onze candidats au total qui ne parle
pas français
je ne sais pas vraiment si on peut
l'expliquer en tous les cas j'ai été
comme bien d'autres surpris de cette de
cette attitude surtout qu'il y avait eu
l'exemple tout de même d'air canada il y
a quelques mois de cela mais on a
vraiment l'antre on a vraiment
l'impression que que la scène ne se ne
s'est pas préoccupé ici de l'impact de
sa de sa décision qui ne tient pas non
plus compte du contexte dans lequel ils
évoluent un contexte où figurent
également la langue on le sait bien il
ya une question linguistique importante
ici au québec et au canada en fête le ça
fait partie des langues officielles
et le cn est soumis à la loi sur les
langues officielles le gouvernement
fédéral se contente de dire ben faut que
l'entreprise montre l'exemple est ce que
le gouvernement devra aller beaucoup
plus loin que de simplement demandé aux
entreprises de montrer l'exemple mais
encore une fois on repose on fait
reposer les choses sur une démarche
volontaire j'allais dire des entreprises
on peut quand même se poser la question
de la pertinence de cette de cette
position dans la mesure où ça fait quand
même quelques temps déjà qu'on critique
le manque de mordant de la loi sur les
langues sur les officiels d'ailleurs le
projet actuellement en cours c 32 vise à
renforcer par exemple les pouvoirs du
commissaire donc on voit quand même
qu'on a qu'on est dans le dans le bon
chemin
encore faut-il que ce projet de loi
aboutisse en attendant on fait reposer
les choses sur le volontariat sur le
lâcher quoi
le projet de loi vise à étendre
l'utilisation du français aux
entreprises privées de compétence
fédérale alors bien entendu va y avoir
des seuils qui vont
ils vont être définis mais quand même en
étant la portée de la loi et on renforce
notamment les pouvoirs également du
commissaire ce sont deux pistes ici
intéressante 1 qui vont dans le même
objectif à savoir renforcer
l'utilisation de la langue française est
ce que est ce que c'est un problème de
taille on ne parlait d'air canada qui a
eu ses enjeux on parle aussi donc du
canadien national aujourd'hui est ce que
c'est un problème de taille ça la
non-représentation la non présence des
francophones dans les directions et dans
les conseils d'administration de grandes
entreprises au canada
on a tendance à vous répondre non c'est
un problème à mon avis qui n'est pas lié
à la taille de l'entreprise mais bien
entendu le problème de la taille joue
dès lors que vous êtes sur des grandes
entreprises qui sont en concurrence
concurrents sur des marchés par exemple
étasunien ou même des marchés à l'autre
bout du à l'autre bout du monde dont
bien entendu la taille joue quand même
un rôle ici sur la question de la langue
ici notamment pour les autres directions
et les conseils d'administration et les
entreprises aux activités
internationales ou intercontinentales
est sale exactement est ce à dire qu'il
ya pas assez de représentants de
candidats francophones
j'ose le dire compétent pour occuper ces
postes là
pour écouter j'en doute j'en doute parce
que on sait bien que tout de même le
québec depuis de nombreuses années à des
organisations de formation pour siéger
dans des conseils d'administration
on a des gens de plus de mieux en mieux
formés plus en plus éduqués
également je pense que c'est davantage
un manque de volonté peut-être un manque
de vision également de la part du cn moi
je suis étonné qu'il n'ait pas trouvé de
candidat francophone parfaitement
bilingue il y en a sur la place de
montréal tu me place financière
importante pour prendre le cas de de
montréal par exemple et ils ne sont pas
seuls parce qu'on parle d'air canada qui
est maintenant dirigée par un pdg qui
peine à s'exprimer en français
snc lavalin également qui est dirigée
par un pdg unilingue anglais la banque
laurentienne
il n'y a pas plus québécois rrq la
banque laurentienne qui est dirigé par
par une p dg qui vient de toronto à qui
nous avons demandé des entrevues qui ne
peut pas nous donner d'entrevue en
français est-ce que sk prend un problème
fondamental dans la sensibilité le
respect de la loi et la sensibilité de
l'importance de parler français au
canada et au québec oui vous avez vous
avez parfaitement raison et je pense
qu'il faut pas cacher la question je
pense que pour la communauté francophone
c'est particulièrement important moi
j'ai eu les sangles le sentiment qu'avec
l'entreprise scène on avait quand même
un mépris de la communauté aux
francophones une note l'importance
reconnue à 7 à cette communauté et les
exemples que vous avez donnée monsieur
fillon illustre illustre parfaitement je
veux dire on peut très bien ne pas
parler français mais on peut être quand
même francophone passif ou au moins dire
quelques mots là où on s'en contente de
plus en plus à l'extrême où on ne se
préoccupe pas du tout de la question
linguistique alors qu'on nous parle
beaucoup de diversité à bon escient
d'ailleurs et c'est une très bonne chose
mais il y aurait peut-être cette
diversité également linguistique qui
devrait entrer en jeu notamment au
canada ou encore plus au québec vous
avez tout à fait raison et la diversité
dans les directions des entreprises est
de plus en plus promu de provenance de
genre est ce que l'on est ce qu'on a
oublié les langues officielles
mais je pense que oui il me semble qu'on
les a qu'on les a oubliés c'est le rôle
du gouvernement je crois de le rappeler
et je repense encore plus au québec
parce que vraiment le français on le
sait c'est la langue c'est la langue
première dans la province et le siège
social de ces elle se trouve ouais c'est
ça qui l'ont incroyable dans cette
histoire du cn itie donc effectivement
la diversité linguistique c'est un
aspect qui me semble à ne pas à ne pas
négliger d'autant que le français est
souvent mal vu dans les affaires il ya
des études qui aujourd'hui montre très
bien que que le français est également
une langue des affaires et une lampe
d'avenir dans le domaine des achats ne
faut pas l'oublier absolument il votre
show rien merci pour cette analyse ce
soir merci à vous pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i cirdi